thank you
hello hello
[Music]
g'day run can you hear us
yep
sweet
I can see one familiar face
I think Carissa Kiki is like everywhere
decline yourself
oh thank you for unmuting me for a
second I thought you you were not
letting me speak
well you have like a full podcast to set
up I do
I'm also wearing my rocket
um
hoodie sweatshirt thingy because I
thought Leandro would have his rocket in
the background and I now I just look
silly
where are you guys
in our co-working space Oh very cool is
that where we always see the Christmas
store somewhere in some Corner yes that
that's like in the meeting room but
today
everybody left so we can use the whole
Space
very cool
I guess we can just wait a couple of
minutes for people
to
join
maybe can you speak
yes can you hear me yeah because uh okay
I I am feeling troubles with my video
for some reason some
trying to figure that out
okay it works
oh cool t-shirt
oh yeah that's I I just unpacked it and
just bought it uh
what time is it now for you
so it's
9 30.
in the evening
no thanks thanks for taking the time I
know it's fine I'm I'm anyway
um working in European Time Zone
um this entire weekend next so it's all
chill
hey Maria how's it going
hi can you hear me yeah nice to see you
yeah nice
yeah everything is going nice I've just
like finished working
um yeah I'm really looking forward to
this uh reading session
you have a copy of the book right
yeah cool so you're probably one of the
experts here you probably know more
about it than we do
yeah sure more than the writers
well to be honest I kind of forgot it
it's like when you finish your thesis
it's like cram and then you create
sorry for anyone who came here expecting
to learn something you know deep and
meaningful about Transformers from us
was there a particular chapter that just
did not want to get written because I
struggle with that sometimes in like
paper sections and
be cool to to learn about how giving
birth to a book
how was it I think it's more more
painful than actual birth
no but I think that the one that took by
part of bonus was I think the the
pre-training from scratch section
because like a lot of the Transformers
and accelerate API was like being
developed to work with one chapter so it
was a it was the type call to to get it
in in time
and also I think it was a probably twice
as long at the beginning
yeah another chapter that was really
tough to write not Implement was the
Transformers Anatomy one
um and like figuring out how you
introduce the concepts at the right
points in the book because you don't
want to like overwhelm people in chapter
one and uh I remember like Andrew and I
shared that chapter
backlines before we found roughly what
we wanted to do
um because I was I had this crazy
ambition to train the Transformer like
from scratch in that chapter like as in
not pre-training but you know just train
a an encoder to do classification
um but then yeah it was just getting too
crazy and
yeah it was uh it was pain
ful super exciting um
you mentioned that the training from
scratch chapter was happening as the
code was being developed I would imagine
it was a great stress test for the
people developing
yeah I think it was a lot of stress for
both sides like I think the two things
that were implemented for that chapter
was like in data sets there's not a
feature that you can stream data
and that was being built while we were
using it oh
accelerate but also pretty new and I
think that was one of the first projects
where we like trained a pretty large
model for a long time is accelerated
there were a lot of fixes
along the way which is the good thing
yeah that was also the case for big
signs a lot of stress tests for like
some weird
like obscure part of the library that
just failed at the scale we were trying
to do things at and it's super
interesting to see how like these
projects
flow back into open source
oh it's recording
yeah we got the notification as soon as
we joined that it was being recorded the
brother is now watching
yes it sounds a bit like you actually
want to start a podcast I wish you could
continue with your questions
what are you drinking while it was like
coffee at six in the evening I'm
drinking yeah I'm drinking
beer makes sense coffee does not
yeah I mean it depends on how like fun
you want this session to become
see I'm clearly the fun one out of the
two of us
yeah we didn't need beverages to know
that
thanks
yeah I guess we're now five minutes in
so we could as well get started
formally uh welcome everyone to the
reading group uh it's been a while since
the book has been out but we felt like
there has been some requests to like go
through the book together uh in some
form uh be it like a reading group or
something similar and so we thought
um it's better late than never
and this is our first session
um
today uh Louis VB and and we are here to
to go through a chapter and maybe we can
just start with like a brief
introduction
um my name is Leandro I'm a machine
learning engineer in the open source
team at how you face
I've joined talking face uh not that
long after we finished writing the book
uh in a sense like working on the book
was the the longest interview I ever did
uh now since yeah a little bit more than
a year I'm in the open source team
you want it yeah yourself so yeah g'day
everyone my name is Lewis and um
according to clip I am a close-up of a
person wearing a white shirt um who
happens to also be Australian but has an
extremely long forehead
um so if you haven't seen this check out
the clip interrogator where you can get
basically insulted by Machine learning
models but more seriously I'm also an
engineer in the open source team at how
you face I I work on the Transformers
and Optimum libraries and it was the
same I've been here for about a year and
a half so roughly a similar experience
for the Andra just after the book and
then joined
next
uh
because he muted himself
um hello I'm I'm Ruby I'm a student
researcher at the University of
Stuttgart I basically break all sorts of
things when it comes to audio and
sometimes Next Generation
Um I am also a hug and face fellow and
um yeah um you might have previously
been uh part of my boring audio sessions
um and and so on I'm looking forward to
this
um to this journey with you all together
and yeah
thank you so much for being here
sounds good thanks
um
so
let me oops
um let me quickly briefly talk about
organization
um the way we want to run this uh
reading group is like as a community so
it shouldn't be just me and Lewis and
Bibi talking but we want anybody to be
able to participate
um so this week uh it's us that
organized it but in the following weeks
if you feel like you you're at a chapter
and you want to talk about it uh we
welcome or almost ask that somebody else
like takes over we're happy to like
support and we will also join the
sessions
um maybe not all of us all the time but
uh at least one of us some of the time
um so the reason me we're co-authors of
the book there's also Tom Wolfe uh who
said like he would be uh interested in
joining a few sessions
um so what we expect for this session is
that before
the sessions that you go through the
chapters so that we can like summarize
the the the the the
content of the chapter pretty quickly uh
together and then spend most of the time
like in on the interesting Partridge is
like your questions and discussions
um
uh around the book
um so the idea is that we probably
present for 10 15 minutes uh take the
content of of a book chapter and then
the rest of the chapter is is dedicated
to to discussions
um
we also announced that's not on that
list here that this reading group should
also help people
with contributing to to open source and
this week we're going to focus mostly on
the book but starting from next week we
also going to have like some fraction of
like the reading group dedicated to
learning about how to contribute to open
source how
for example one can open an issue create
CRS and interact with the ecosystem
so the timeline is today is the the
kickoff session
um we're gonna walk through like the
very first chapter in the book which is
more a very high level uh chapter it's
not too much code
next week and not next week but in two
weeks we're going to do it in like two
week intervals uh we're gonna talk about
text classification which is like the
first Hands-On chapter and then after
that essentially you can decide which
chapter you want to look at next we're
going to do some votes
um maybe we take like a sub selection of
all the chapters for for the vote but
essentially we we're Guided by your
interest so if there is a particular
chapter that you find interesting you
can vote for it and then we look at that
first
so
[Music]
um
yeah I think that's pretty much it
um let me
get started with like the the very first
um chapter which is hello Transformers
and um
one thing that's uh
that chapter goes through is a little
bit like the the evolution of
Transformers like if you start looking
at like the Transformers paper you see
like a very complicated diagram and it
might not be so clear how that diagram
came to be it doesn't sound it doesn't
look like something very like intuitive
that you think like uh anybody could
have come up with that
um but if you if we go a little bit like
through the evolution steps be between
different architectures
um it becomes a little bit more apparent
why Transformers came to be
and so the very first thing that you can
see here is like an RNN so a recurring
your network
um how a return your network works is
that it gets some input t
and then it passes that input through
its its this so-called like RNN cell and
then part of of what comes out of that
cell is the state that can be used for
example later on for for classification
or something and there's a tiny part
that the RNN feeds to itself
and one way to visualize that a little
bit more intuitive is if you unroll such
an ornament in time so if you think
about
um an RNN that gets like several inputs
input one input two input three that
could be for example be words in a in a
text or in a sequence of numbers
so the the cell gets like the first
input it generates the first state and
then in the for the next step it passes
some information to itself
and it does that uh for at each step so
some information always gets passed to
itself at the next step
until you arrive like at the end of the
sequence and that self-feeding mechanism
is what allows the RNN to keep track of
things and have kind of like a memory
of what happened previously so at the
very end when you come to State T the
the the the model has like the ability
to know what happened at the very first
uh input so if that's a sentence it for
example knows what uh the subject of a
sentence was
and these rnns are very nice
um they've been used for quite a while
if you want to do something
[Music]
um
like uh
translation usually you you use two
ordinance to for such a tasks
um so here we have the example of
Transformers are great and in German
transforms in closed static
and one way you can address this
translation problem is by having an
encoder block very essentially your your
input sequence gets fed through that RNN
and then at the very end you take like
the very last state of that RNN and you
feed it to the decoder block which has
like a separate and new RNN cell which
is uh just there to decode that state
which should like kind of capture the
meaning of the sentence into the
sentence in the new language
um
that was like the the default way to do
these things like a couple of years ago
one issue that you have is that
everything that you need kind of on the
right hand side needs to be encoded in
the state so if the state doesn't
capture all the information that's
necessary to come up with like the the
translation on the right hand side and
the decoder block has no chance to to
properly uh decode
um that state in into the translation
foreign
like all the states to the RNN to the
decoder block
um but that's also not so easy because
then you have like a lot of information
that needs to flow from the left to the
right hand side
so this part in the middle like that
state that's usually uh like an
information bottleneck
for for the the translation
um it didn't take so long that people
then came up with like a new way to do
that that's a little bit more efficient
and instead now of just having the the
last state that gets transferred to the
decoder block you transfer all the
states but I said like just before
that's usually not ideal because then
you need to process all that information
for example if you want to pass that to
the RNN cell on the right hand side you
would need to like stack the this date
somehow or average them which might also
uh lead to to like some lost information
and one way you can do that is by adding
an attention mechanism and the job of
the attention mechanism is essentially
figuring out which state is important
for which Step so if you're for example
here at the RNN
uh the second decoding step and you want
to know
um you want to decode like the second
word then probably it makes sense to
look at the second word in the first
sequence so the attention mechanism
could be heavily focusing on on that
second word
and that's like where the original
attention came from
um it wasn't in Transformers attention
was there already before
and one thing one cool thing that you
can do is you can visualize how the
attention looks like in such a
translation model
so here you can see two sentences one in
English and one in French and it's about
like an agreement on the European
economic area
and you can see the attention is
visualized in that Matrix so at each
step you can see to which token in the
other language and the model attempts to
so when you want to translate the then
the model looks at the first token
agreement is
and so on but one thing that's
interesting is like if you look at your
European economic area in French the the
order of the words is reversed and you
can see that in the attention
essentially
so that's cool with uh with attention
you can actually make use of all the
states by having that focusing mechanism
and so people thought if
um you can at each step decide which
state you want to use why do you also
need the RNN cell to pass information
between those steps
and that's essentially how Transformers
came to be is like people got rid of all
the rnns so you see there's no Arrow
anymore between the tokens there's no
information that flows between them but
the attention mechanism makes sure that
at each step the model can attend to any
token that it wants and so you can in
addition to replacing the rnns now also
the encoder block has an intention
because it lost its uh recurrent ability
and that's like a very simple view of
like how the Transformer architecture
looks like
and if you go to the paper
um you see like that very complicated
graph that I mentioned at the very
beginning but under the hood
um you can think of it as like that
simplified diagram and as you dive
deeper into Transformers more and more
of these like Steps gonna be gonna
become more apparent especially when we
look at the anatomy chapter
um of of the book
uh we're going to see like what these
multi-headed tension mechanisms are or
uh yeah that's and the input embeddings
but the The crucial part is you get rid
of the rnns you just use feed forward
networks and you make use of that
attention to capture like the the SQL
sequential information
that is like
one of the main ingredients that makes
Transformers so so widely used is that
attached mechanism and this feed for
networks that are way more uh way easier
to train than recurrent neural networks
but there is a second thing and that's
um transfer learning and transfer
learning is the idea that you can reuse
a model that has been trained on some
data on a new task
so let's say you go back 10 or even five
years ago the left hand side would be
how people would train language or
models for like language tasks you have
some domain maybe you want to do
sentiment classification you train a
model on that and that model is just
used to make sentiment predictions you
have another domain maybe you want to
like identify names in a text you would
train a new model from scratch on that
new task and that model would just make
predictions on that
the idea with transfer learning is that
instead of just retraining or training a
new model every time you have a new task
you can reuse a model
several times
now the idea is that you pre-train a
model in in text it's usually you train
a model on like large amounts of text
to for example predict an expert in
sequence of words or predict the masked
word
and after you pre-trained that model you
can use it for several tasks
and you don't need that much data
anymore so if you have a pre-explain
model that's been trained on a lot of
text and you want to fine tune that uh
you want to train it on sensory
classification you can do that with like
just a few hundreds samples maybe and
Achieve like great performance or as
like before when you had to train a
model every time you have a new task you
also needed a lot of data to do it
and that's like the the second aspect of
of transform models that made them so
popular that transfer learning works
very well with them
and we're gonna see probably next time
when we do like uh
text classification how that works like
in in more detail
so to wrap up kind of like where
Transformers came from I thought we
could have a look at like the timeline
and how crazy it has been like in just
in the past four years now or yeah four
and a half years
um it started with Transformers that's
essentially that diagram I showed that
was like the first paper that showed
that without recurrence just with
attention feed for networks you can
achieve like state-of-the-art
performance in translation
um they didn't think about transfer
learning at that point
but it didn't take long like a few half
a year later so uh well and fit came out
which was still a recurrent neural
network but uh they kind of cracked how
to do the transfer learning so they
pre-trained a recurrent neural network
on Wikipedia and they showed that you
can easily fine tune that to do
sentiment classification and that was
like the the first time
transfer learning really worked for for
NLP
soon after GPT came around the the very
first version which is like a model
that's very good at generating text
um soon after bird modeled by Google
that's very good at all
um language understanding tasks like
classification or
question answering these type of things
and that's like the first very popular
model that was used to do
NLP bit transfer learning between
Transformers
um gpt2 was a model that came soon after
which was essentially scaling up cheap
T1 and discovering that by just scaling
up models you can like improve their
capabilities that led to like a lot of
like follow-up work uh in the past few
years where people figured out that
they're actually lost to that that you
can predict how well a model performs if
you just make it bigger and training for
longer
um and 52 had like impressive
capabilities when it came to generation
there was a famous example where you
would feed a model and that unicorns
were discovered in the Andes and the
model will go on and generate a whole
newspaper article about that story
and since then you can see this is just
like a subset of all the models that
have been released in the past couple of
years but essentially every few months
there is a new one and we're gonna look
at a few of them
uh in the book not all of them some of
them have like uh special architecture
some of them have been strained for
longer or have been scaled up
um but uh
since then the the ball has been rolling
quite fast
so that's it from my part
um for now
um I'm gonna hand over to Bibi who's
gonna
show you
um
a little bit more applied how you can
use Transformers in practice
all right let me see if I can share my
screen
is it visible
yeah
oh perfect
um oh
clicked on the wrong button
all right so um up until now we
basically went through like how dead
Transformers came to be and what kind of
um you know what kind of architectures
and what kind of findings and and you
know what sort of intuition led to the
um uh led to the
the sort of architecture that
Transformers is
um now let's let's look at the the
Transformers landscape and let's look at
um
how
um how we can use some of these models
um without having to sort of
um uh you know go down into the trenches
um and and just like test out how they
work and you know what kind of
applications can they
um help us out with right
um so when it comes to national language
processing pretty much every task starts
with a piece of text right um in this
case we I basically took the text from
uh the book itself which is a made up
customer feedback
um as you can see it's it's basically
dear Amazon last week I ordered blah
blah blah blah uh sincerely
um right
um and now what we're going to do is
we're going to take this text and we're
gonna uh try and try and see what kind
of different
um national language processing tasks
can we apply on this text to generate
further
um insights from it so I'm just gonna
quickly switch to a collab notebook
um just to Quick heads up all of these
notebooks as well as the collabs would
be available to you shortly after the
um after the session is over
um so uh don't worry if you don't
um follow it fully
um just yet you would get enough plenty
of chances afterwards to to go in
um this is basically a version adapted
from the
um from the
um the code Snippets used in the
um in the book itself so if you've gone
through it you won't face much troubles
just gonna quickly see if I can
all right
um
so um oh this is probably a bit too much
okay so um again we start off with the
same text
um as we saw before so this is a
um a customer feedback or
um you know some sort of a a customer uh
saying something
um to uh some sort of a agency or sort
uh now let's
um let's basically take this take this
text and now let's pass it through a
text classification Pipeline on
Transformers uh using the Transformers
library and um see what kind of response
do we get out of it out of it what's
happening over here is we're essentially
um taking a text classification pipeline
from the Transformers library and we're
just we're just passing the text to it
uh straight up
um without any
um like without giving it any context of
what what sort of outputs do we want out
of it or um and so on so
um at the like
in the beginning what it's gonna like
right now what it's gonna do is it's
it's gonna do sentiment classification
on this so it's going to take this uh
text and it's gonna
um um it's it's gonna give us one of the
two outputs either it is positive or it
is negative along with what's the
probability of it being positive or
negative and um so on so we just um
instantiate the the classifier um which
is basically calling the pipeline
um along with the text classification
um task and um then we just pass the
text to the to the classifier and we
take the outputs out
um so uh as as we saw as we saw in the
text itself um that this is this was a
sort of negative
um uh text as you can see from uh pretty
much this uh this line
um that you know the person ordered in
Optimus Prime action figure and well
they got a Megatron
um long side uh
um and um so you can basically see that
we did not really trade in a model for
it right so we just we we just use the
um a language model that's available on
the hug and face Hub and we just like
passed this text to it and without uh it
seeing this particular example
um um this or like examples of this
specific type it was able to
um uh give us a fairly reasonable uh
output which is negative and also with a
score of 0.9
um and so on right now that's that's
just one part of it we can also do like
all sorts of other things so for example
we can also do named entity recognition
which is
um essentially sending the text and then
identifying different entities from the
text itself right so entities can be
something like location or can be
something like date can be a currency
um or or can be a name uh and so on and
so forth and over here as well what
we're doing is we're from the same
pipeline
um uh for the task ner
um we're instantiating uh name Dental
recognition tagger and we're just
passing our text to it
um so again just just two lines of code
um and
um we're we're passing our text to it
when we look at the
um when we look at the the output you
can see that it classified Amazon as as
an organization uh Germany was
classified as a as a location
um
drawn within Megatron that got split uh
because of the way it was tokenized
um got classified as a person
um if I'm not wrong and Bumblebee got
classified as a person as well right and
um again
um keep in mind that um this is just
taking an off-the-shelf uh language
model and then just passing the
um like passing the
um the text through it
um uh for the specific task
um then we can we can go One Step Beyond
and um and we can do
um some fancy things like question
answering right wherein we instantiate
um
sorry
uh pipeline for um question answering
and we just uh we we pass the text as
context and then we
um we ask the question what does the
customer actually want or like what does
the customer want
um in in this particular record and
um it gave a pretty clear answer that um
the customer wants an exchange of uh
Megatron because they received Megatron
and they wanted
um Optimus Prime right
um and all we did over here is we um
we pass the the text as context which
was the uh the input text and then we
passed the question
um and um we passed it through the
pipeline uh the the Q a pipeline and we
got the following output
um along with The Confidence Code
um we can also do something like
summarize
um like long pieces of
um text and and then summarize them into
short Snippets
um so in this case we
um instantiate a summarization Pipeline
and um we
um we give it certain constraints so for
example we we want to take the 200
length sort of input and we wanted to
summarize it into into a 45 length um
input and let's see what the uh what the
model comes up with so the model
um basically says that Bumble D up sorry
bumblebee ordered in Optimus Prime
action figure from your online store in
Germany unfortunately when I opened the
package I discovered my horror that I
had been sent the action figure of
Megatron so well not too bad
um it basically figured out the uh the
gist of what was there within the
um within the original text and um it
still conveys the same meaning
um more or less
um
and um again I just wanted like
emphasize the fact that you don't have
to like
um you don't have to know a lot just yet
uh in order for you to like play around
with these pipelines you can also just
like once you have access to this um
this notebook or just go to the
notebooks repository
um you you can pretty much just take any
text that you get your hands on and and
then just like play around with the with
the with the pipelines with the
different
um arguments that they expect and and so
on and and you can um just just from off
off the shares models you can get quite
good results
um and and you know quite quite a good
intuition of of what's Happening uh
under the hood as well
um then now let's let's take the same
text and let's try and translate it into
German
um so for this we
um we instantiate our translation
pipeline which is from English to German
and we specify our model
um for it um which was fine-tuned
specifically for this task
um and we we pass it to the translator
Pipeline and let's look at the
um look at the output
um my German's not that great
um but from the very little that I know
it it looks sort of okayish
it it got quite a lot of words correct
um at least I see Optimus Prime over
there
and uh um yeah so it it just worked
quite all right just just from the
um um just from the text that we gave to
it
um using the the model that we passed
um to it
um now let's let's try and generate a
response to bumblebee
um
by generating some text and so what
we'll do over here is we'll
um we'll pass we'll create a prompt
which is dear bumblebee I am sorry to
hear that your order was mixed up and um
uh then we pass it along uh to uh to the
model and uh now let's see
um what sort of a response
um does it generate so just for
reference this is the this is the
original
um message which bumblebee sent to
Amazon
um sorry Amazon and this is the response
that our model created so which is clear
bumblebee I'm sorry to hear that your
order was mixed up the order was
mislabeled which is very common
um that's very honest uh but I can
appreciate
um it because it was my understanding
um the day before your order and so on
and so forth
um well I mean like it it's it does make
sense from from from like a grammatical
standpoint we may not want to like
um share this word about him uh with the
with the with the customer but um the
model pretty much like generated text
which is um sort of meaningful and is
also uh to an extent grammatical um as
well so
um we like if if there was a um if there
was a language model fine-tuned
specifically for customer service
responses then I put would of course
give a much better risk much better
result than just using
um
an off-the-shelf language model which is
not fine-tuned for this specific purpose
um so what we looked at so far was how
we can
um you know without writing too much
code how we can just like mess around
with certain pipelines which are
provided by the Transformers Library
itself and you know try out different
tasks here and there and um and and and
see what the what the response is uh to
that
um can be uh I would encourage you all
to
um to you know play around with this as
much as you can
um and you know just just try and break
this and like try to find edge cases and
and then you know
um share them on the reading group uh
channel on Discord um so that everyone
can you know
um comment on that and and and so on
um one thing uh that you can also do
from these models that you know
um later on when we go through like
other chapters and so on and you know in
case you find human model or in case you
come across you know one of these um
um one of these pipelines and you want
to share it with someone is that you can
package these um these models into great
yo applications which can then be shared
with with different people and you know
they can they can try it out um as well
these this can also be uploaded on
hogging paste spaces uh more on this in
the next session
um and and as you can see like what what
have what we've done over here is we
just like create a very simple Radio
application uh which is defined in an
interface which takes this one question
um question underscore answer function
um and this question underscore answer
function takes two parameters both are
text types so there is the first one is
the context uh the second one is the
question and we instantiate a question
answering Pipeline and uh we get the
output from it and return the output uh
in in output so just with like five
lines of code you can create a decent
looking application
um
um which you can then use for
um all sorts of different text
um and so on so let's try this out I'm
not sure if this still works but let's
see
um
so I'm just gonna give it some weird
input the customer wants happiness uh
the question uh what does the customer
want
um let's see if it still works
oh yeah so it it does work like this was
like fairly simple
um I practically gave it the answer uh
but you can see that uh just with five
lines of code you can have like an icui
wherein you can you know play around
with your models um yourself and and
also you can share it along with
um you know your friends and with the
community
um and with the reading group for for
them to test out your models and you
know provide you some feedback or um you
know just just try it out for fun
um as well
um so that was basically like a quick
run through of what sort of of some of
the uh pipelines that you can use there
there is a huge list of pipelines that
you can
um who
did I stop sharing
ah sorry
um
okay
um I was trying to create and like open
a new tab but for some reason the zoom
thing is not letting me um open it but
yeah you can find out like all sorts of
different pipelines that you can that
you can play around with in the hunt and
face talks um we can check it out in a
in a bit and uh yeah um again I would
encourage you to uh play around with it
as much as you can or as much as you
desire
um so I'm gonna head back to the
slides real quick
so now so up until now we've seen uh
just a quick recap so we've seen uh what
sort of architecture the what sort of
architecture sort of powers the the
Transformer
um type models and what led to it we saw
um what sort of tasks or like briefly
saw some of the tasks that you can sort
of do with these uh language models or
these um or these models in itself and
now comes the big question that
um given the rapidly changing sort of
landscape that we
um that we are in wherein like there is
a new paper every other week or there's
a new mortality of the week how does one
sort of build uh or like apply these
these architectures that are you know
um that are better than um the ones that
we saw uh in our pipelines right and
this is like a fairly
complicated topic because
um you would you would first have to
sort of like the way you would go about
it typically would be that you would you
would implement this this model
architecture in some sort of code so you
would you would create either torch
tensorflow or jacks or you know
something like that you would create a
code base for it and then you would uh
you would first of all find the
pre-trained weights um that you can um
sort of import in this architecture or
like load in this
um in this architecture uh and you know
if they are available in the first place
that is
um and then you would sort of recreate
the way
um the authors of that paper sort of
pre-process their inputs um and and like
you know pass them through the model and
then like whatever output you get you
would have to do some sort of post
processing on on top of it
um and and then of course like for for
fine tuning it further or for you know
just like training it from scratch you
will have to
um you know Define data loaders for it
you would have to Define what sort of
Optimizer
um um you want for a defined loss
function and so so on so all of this can
be like really really daunting
um just to be able to sort of apply
um a machine learning architecture right
and uh not to mention by the time you
you do all of this there would be
another uh
um you know language model or another
architecture already out there
um and and you know um uh then you would
do this whole thing all over again for
that right and um
so so how do we how do we sort of deal
with this
um this is where the sort of hugging
face ecosystem
um comes to rescue
um so when it comes to the overall
ecosystem
um it's it's much more than this but but
just a sort of concise
um uh the overall ecosystem
um we have the Transformers Library
which which basically has
um the code base of I I think by now
like hundreds of different models across
like language Version audio text
um and so on
um we have tokenizers for uh for for
pre-processing as well as like preparing
the data for for the um to input into
these models we have data sets wherein
you can
um carefully sort of Version Control as
well as stream data from uh from the
hugging face Hub
um and and you know then then train your
uh then train a specific model that you
want for your particular use case
um and we also have the accelerate Drive
activity which which heads in um you
know certain optimizations uh in the way
you
um you train these
um these models right and all of these
sort of models data sets um and and you
know um
metrics and like everything
um sort of becomes a part of of this
having Pace Hub wherein you can sort of
upload your models that you fine-tuned
or uh you know you can upload your data
sets you can do it and um if you if if
you want to share it with the community
then you can make them open source or or
like public or you can also create
private models private data sets um and
you can also use libraries like evaluate
uh to then like evaluate
um the the predictions that you get from
your models uh in a standardized format
um and so on and all of these sort of
models are also well documented in the
um in the hugging phase
um docs as well
um actually let's
quickly go and um and see
um these uh models real quick
uh one second
so this is how the The Hub pretty much
looks like so if you if you click on
models you can see that right now across
different tasks and so on there are 79
514 models um you can choose what sort
of task you're looking for so say for
example uh you want to do
um say question answering then you can
click on question answering and you can
see that there are 2400 models for it
you can then subset it I think you can
go back to the tag list you can then
like subset it on what data sets what
they uh what they trained on what
languages
um
what they trained on so say for example
if I click on German
um then you can see that there are 12
models for question answering
um specifically for
um the German language right so you can
you can pretty much like
um
sort of slice and dice the amount of
models that are available on the Hub for
your specific use case uh quite easily
right
um You can also do
um across like different libraries so
you if you want something which has
tensorflow compatible weights then you
can click on tensorflow
um if you click on pytorch then
um it it would show up for pi torch
Jackson like so on and so forth right
um uh so this is modeled
um similarly there are data sets you can
do
um the same sort of thing so if you if
you're for your particular use case if
you want to find a data set
um for a given task so say for example
we want something for translation and
you know we we want uh something in say
again German
um then you can see that
um just by this we we have data sets
which have
um language pairs for German
um and there are 47 of them and you know
you can you can basically like sort them
um look at the most liked uh data set
look at the most downloaded one and so
on and so forth right
um so in general like uh when it comes
to
um when it comes to like fine-tuning
your own model or you know
um just like trying out different models
um I would encourage you to just just
like check out uh models and like for
your specific task just look at which
model you can play around with
um uh first and then you know just like
pipe them into a pipeline and then just
like see how how they perform in your um
for your particular data set and then
sort of look into fine tuning them which
will cover
um later on
um and so on and
um yeah so it it basically works out
um quite well
um
in this case okay let's go back to the
slides
um
and um
then um so now we've seen like how we
can
um play around with these models and
like we've we've sort of looked at like
at a very high level
um you know how we can find different
different models and how we can find
different data sets and uh and so on we
haven't looked at you know much of code
yet but don't worry we'll we look at
plenty uh in the upcoming sessions uh
but I just wanted to like spend like
quick five minutes on the challenges uh
that that come along with using
um uh such models right
um so one of the first model uh like one
one of the first challenges is the
language barrier itself majority of the
research
um for Transformers has been uh pretty
much been in English language
um there are multiple reasons for it
like one of the biggest reason is that
um
just like the just like the data itself
for like English language is is is
available by truckloads um you know like
you can you you can find so much on in
in Wikipedia
um you can find so much from Reddit you
can find so much from Twitter and so on
and so forth because like a
um uh generally like communication uh
across uh across the world happens in
English so we just have so much data for
it that that a lot of researchers
um research has been done in this
language right
um what this means is that um quite a
lot of models are not really available
um for low resource languages like for
example Taiwanese or
um
um
um or say for example Latvian
um and and so on right there are like uh
new multilingual models and so on which
which are covered later on in the book
um that help sort of solve this problem
uh to an extent uh but by and large this
is still in uh this is still a problem
um or a challenge
um next up um
these models are data hungry so even
though
um we um we apply uh transfer learning
uh which which which reduces the need
for a lot of training data
um for um for a lot of tasks you would
still need like some training data it's
it's not that you can just do like zero
shot and
um uh zero shot meaning that you can
just like throw
um any sort of
um data from from any domain and and
then just like expect it to work
um it still requires like quite a lot of
data
um which in most cases uh would would
would you know have to be either hand
annotated or like
um have to be
um sort of processed in a certain way
for the for the model and so on right so
um yeah this is still like this is also
um a challenge
um for these modules
um next up is um is working with with
long documents so um uh the attention
method uh itself it works well we've
seen that however it is a it is a very
extensive process it is like from in in
like um computer science terms it is a
big O of n Square process
um um so meaning that you you basically
Traverse
um the input twice oh well like each
input like each sort of token within an
input with itself like
um throughout and that just means that
um computationally as well as like
memory wise this is a very expensive
process so um this basically limits the
um the length of sort of documents that
you can pass through the model whilst
it's
um it's learning
um or whilst
um it's training and so on
um there are now uh quite a lot of
methods
um to sort of circumvent
um this entire problem but it's it's not
like completely uh solved
um so for example there are a certain
attention uh approximation methods like
uh nice strong approximation or
something like reformer
um which helps
um which helps this case to to some
extent uh but yeah still like passing
long documents
um is you know still inexpensive process
at the end of the day
um
um then you know as with like all deep
learning models uh these models are
still like I still black boxes
um to a to a much much more extent
um like you know Finding why exactly did
a Model make certain prediction is um is
like you know and and you know saying
that with a
um uh with the Cent percent sort of
accuracy is
um is still not possible
um so yeah so um this is also one of the
um one of the challenges with it as
opposed to like classical sort of um
statistical machine learning realm
um and so on
um uh last but not the least is the is
the biases that these models sort of
come with
um just the just the just the amount of
uh training data that that that has
passed to it uh has a lot of
um you know bias in it in itself so um
they were like a lot of sort of um
discussion when uh gpd4 Chan was
launched which was basically a model
trained on
um uh Fortune
um
is it called repos now like basically
like 4chan sort of communities and so on
like all the texts that was there and it
was just like spewing out really really
really
um uh you know um hurtful uh text and
and you know so on so um um you know if
you it's like like these models still
follow like garbage and garbage out sort
of principles so uh whatever you put in
the model the model would learn that and
uh whatever you put in would always have
some sort of bias
um to it so you know um these models are
riddled with
um these biases by and large
um
so yeah that's that's that's basically
it
um when it comes to the challenges where
Transformers um we will address a lot of
these in the upcoming sessions on like
how you can sort of
um uh use different types of tricks or
different types of architectures or
different types of sort of pre-training
methodologies to
um you know uh address uh some of these
uh but it's it's always good to know uh
what sort of challenges come along with
um with these architectures
okay
um so now we're we're at the end I'm not
sure
um Leandra will do is if you want to
um cover the
uh the next steps
sure so just to keep it brief and that
we have like a couple of minutes to to
answer a few questions
um there's a link to to The Notebook I
believe like in the first bullet point
so you can go to that notebook play
around and mix yourself
um there is also a Discord Channel
um called reading group uh in the roller
Simon Channel you have to ask for the
collaborate role and if you do that then
you get added to the reading group
um and I think most of the
organizational things we're gonna just
post on on that's that channel and it's
like Channel Discord Channel directly
um we all have uh some merch that we can
give away as well as some books
um I'm also gonna post a question about
like access to books if uh you you need
that
maybe we can organize something and I
believe Lewis has also posted the link
where you can look at the book for free
uh at least for a few days
so I think we can now go over or go over
to questions and I'm just gonna allow
anybody to unmute himself if they have a
question
hi I have a question
sure go ahead so hi my name is Nicholas
I'm a data scientist at a non-profit
called World Quant University
and first I just want to congratulate
you guys on the book Louis VB Leandro
this is a great
um series and I love the book I love how
applied it is and I was very impressed
as a teacher how you were able to get it
all to work uh using Google collab for
people who want to get those resources
so like that was a very slick uh piece
of programming that you all did which I
will definitely copy next time I teach a
class that way
um
my question has to do with attention so
I understand that attention you train
attention by these masks right which say
like this is this is the token you need
to pay attention to
but my question is like where do those
masks come from like are they kind of
pre-trained or like you already you're
already telling the model where to
um pay attention to or is it like or is
it kind of auto training where the
attention should be
yeah
um I couldn't take that question
um we're gonna look at that in much more
detail in like one probably of the the
follow-up
um I think there's the anatomy chapter
that goes into more detail into how
attention works
um in short it's like learned so the
model learns what it's looking for and
at the same time it learns how to
represent things that when it's looking
for it it finds it and there's that
concept of queries which are extent
essentially what you're looking for and
keys which are the opposite like if
you're looking for something is that the
thing that you're looking for
um and these things are learned so the
model learns how it needs to encode
questions when it looks for something
and how it needs to represent the
sequences that it finds it when it's
looking for it but everything is learned
end-to-end so it's nothing hard-coded
I'll return it I think yeah anyway thank
you guys that I understand so it's
learned it's not hard-coded got it thank
you
any other questions
well the reading group channel is
already on or us setup one
um it should already be there so you can
go to are you part of Discord
oh yeah yeah
so I think um in order to see the
channel you have to first go to the role
assignment Channel
and then you can select the Emoji
um for collaborate which is like the
party face emoji and then that should
give you access to see the reading group
Channel
collaboration okay okay select that okay
maybe a few questions
I already selected it
so yeah we're already almost there so
there's the role assignment Channel
and you can see the collaborate share
and ask for help that's the role that
you need and so you need to click on
that emoji the party emoji I did it but
I don't see it uh still don't see it we
don't see a reading group Channel it
should be under General
oh now I got it okay thank you right
thanks
Chris already ordered pineapple pizza
great great really appreciate it you
know it's uh this book it's so
enlightening you know I went through a
few chapters
and before this book I would read in
some other Anarchy book like the one by
juraski oh yeah I mean they are yeah
they have a lot of good stuff uh but
they don't show your code example but
with the code example I can understand
much much better and you guys make it so
easy you know you can just one click you
can run its in color app oh man amazing
you know I and I can you know insert
some print statements and say hey how'd
this look like what is this you know
what's the shape of this uh Spencer or
you know a lot of time after you play
around and you know you insert some
print statement oh you understand a
whole lot better
really appreciate it thank you so much
thank you
um maybe we have quite time for like one
last question because we're already a
little bit over time it's like
otherwise we also have plenty of time
next
next session to answer more questions
um hi uh I wanted to ask uh like
generosity zooming out that do you see
like which areas are lstms like things
like lsdm like pre-transformer models
still
you know better than a transformat if
any areas do you see uh in the
application
um
yeah
yeah you can take that you trained lots
of those teams
uh it's been a long time ago but uh I
think there's still some feels like even
in in NLP where people find like that
lstms for some very specific application
they deliver quite well
but I think
um
the the just the fact that the whole
field moved to Transformers is like kind
of detrimental to lstms because like it
gets much less support than Transformers
because now thousands of people are
using Transformers all the libraries
exist you train them and all the
examples so I think just naturally
people use uh less lstms but I don't
think there's like a de facto thing
where lstms perform way better
I mean maybe yeah I think there's a
really interesting discussion actually
uh between Jeremy Howard and other
people on Twitter at the moment around
um you know if you compare the total
compute time of a transformer so
including the pre-training budget plus
the fine-tuning budget then things like
ULM fit are much more efficient provided
you have enough in domain data so the
the idea is that like I think used to
train your Olympic from scratch at your
job right and there that that took quite
a few hours or something so the whole
that's pre-training right so so training
you will fit from scratch
um with pre-training is like orders of
magnitude
faster than a Transformer the downside
is of course that if you want to do more
sophisticated things like question
answering or identity recognition I
think then it's it's a bit less flexible
um another thing I've seen used in in
practice is I'm using lstms for
compression so if you want to suppose
you've got a super duper Transformer
like T5 you know 12 billion parameter
model
um trying to deploy that on like an edge
device is going to be really hard
um so what some people do is they take
the the the model and then they kind of
distill it into an lstm so you're
essentially compressing the the
knowledge that you've gained and then
kind of having a much much smaller model
and you know depending on the task this
can be an efficient way of you know
having something that is very good at
you know language but is much smaller
cool I think we're already like almost
five minutes over time thanks a lot to
everybody for joining we will post more
information on the Discord Channel and
looking forward to see you in two weeks
thanks everyone
thank you bye
thanks for tuning thanks